seit mitte des jahres läuft am
karlsruher institut für technologie dem
kec ein gigantisches experiment hier
geht es darum endlich dem rätsel der
neutrino massen auf die schliche zu
kommen werden darüber berichtet bei
diesem großen rätselraten könnte eine
bestimmte formel helfen die ki des
formel teilchenphysiker physikerin
bezeichnen sie als besonders schön und
elegant aber halten sich die
elementarteilchen an das was in der
formel welt als besonders gilt und was
kann herr kritis vorhersage für masse
der neutrinos beitragen damit wir die
wohl mysteriösesten teilchen unseres
universums endlich verstehen klicks und
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ja keins herzlich
willkommen lieben dank für diesen themen
vorschlag bei whatsapp neutrinos sind
die häufigsten elementarteilchen
überhaupt sie formen galaxien und
bewegen das universum
sie sind elektrisch neutral leicht und
vor allem eins mysteriös oft werden sie
auch als geister teilchen bezeichnet
denn sie rasen durch gewöhnliche materie
wie planeten bäume oder häuser einfach
hindurch anstatt mit ihnen zu
interagieren forschungsteams weltweit
stehen vor einem großen rätsel
wenn es um die masse der neutrinos geht
denn niemand konnte bislang herausfinden
wie schwer die teilchen wirklich sind
200 forscherinnen und forschern
karlsruhe sind an dem sogenannten katrin
experiment beteiligt und forschen hier
an der genauesten waage der welt oder
dem reinsten vakuum auf der erde wir
hatten ja darüber berichtet mit einem
besseren verständnis der neutrinos
könnte man sich langfristig endlich auch
an die grundfragen des universums
heranwagen warum gibt es etwas und warum
gibt es nicht einfach nichts konkret
also warum ist beim urknall ein
ungleichgewicht zwischen materie auf der
einen seite und antimaterie auf der
anderen seite entstanden
zudem könnte das katrin experiment auch
dazu beitragen die sogenannte qi des
formel zu verstehen die wurde 1981 von
einem japaner aufgestellt und stellt
verschiedene arten von elementarteilchen
in zusammenhang
und so sieht diese formel aus konkret
geht es um die massen von mühe und
tauern und elektronen elektronikkette ja
aus dem physik und chemie unterricht
daneben gibt es eben noch zwei
elektronen die deutlich schwerer sind
diese sind 200 mal schwerer als das
elektron und das tauen das mit 3470
elektronen massen eine deutlich größere
massat als das proton wenn ihr euch
jetzt die formel noch einmal anschaut
dann seht ihr auch das ergebnis zwei
drittel ziemlich überraschend dass
hierbei überhaupt so eine runde zahl
herauskommt zudem liegt dieses ergebnis
genau in der mitte der möglichen
extremwerte heißt also das ergebnis wäre
ein drittel wenn die massen von
elektronen und teilen identisch wären
wäre die masse eines teilchens deutlich
schwerer als das der anderen beiden
dann würde das ergebnis eines lauten
doch wo genau liegt der zusammenhang
zwischen diesen drei elementarteilchen
oder anders gefragt gibt es überhaupt
einen zusammenhang oder aber ist das
alles nicht mehr als ein numerischer
zufall
weiterhin ist auch die frage offen warum
elementarteilchen eben die masse haben
die sie haben immer noch sind
forschungsteams nicht in der lage die
masse der teilchen aus einer theorie zu
bestimmen also theoretisch herzuleiten
den exakten wert der masse erhält man
nur durch eine messung der
hilfsmechanismus wurde zwar durch den
nachweis des higgs bosons im jahr 2012
belegt doch auch er kann lediglich
beschreiben wie teilchen zu ihrer masse
kommen nicht wie groß sie ist also durch
das higgs fällt das alles zeigt mal
wieder die grenzen des standardmodells
der teilchenphysik aus natürlich ist es
auch super erfolgreich noch experimente
konnten weiterführende hypothesen wie
etwa die der supersymmetrie also dass
eine symmetrie zwischen teilchen gibt
und sie ineinander um wandelbar sind
bislang noch nicht bestätigen
die formel von herrn colitis jedenfalls
zeigt einen mathematischen zusammenhang
zwischen physikalischen größen
doch die große frage lautet ob deswegen
auf jeden fall auch ein physikalischer
zusammenhang bestehen muss fraglich ob
die natur und das universum sich von
solchen schönen beeindruckende 0
eleganten resultaten beeindrucken lässt
denn warum sollte eine beschreibung der
natur zwingend auch schön sein
auf der anderen seite ist natürlich aber
auch vorstellbar dass diese elegante
formel auf einen uns noch unbekannten
mechanismus hindeutet ganz konkret
ausgedrückt auf naturgesetze die noch
nicht entdeckt wurden ausgeschlossen ist
es keinesfalls dass diese als ästhetisch
gefeierte formel somit mal zur
weltformel aufsteigen könnte wenn ihr
garantiert kein video bei pixum
verpassen wollte zu diesem und allen an
dann abonniert klicks um auch auf
englisch hier einfach draufklicken denn
da gibt es auch videopremieren wie das
exklusivinterview mit dem harvard
professor luc beim letzten mal hier geht
es weiter mit sensation portal to new
kind of physics has been open wir sehen
uns auf dem englischen kanal von klicks
um hoffentlich wieder mut zu